(intro music)
(audience clapping)
- Nice to meet you.
- All right, where do I sit?
(audience cheering and clapping)
- [Kelly] You're right here, come on over.
- Welcome back,
do you know Henry?
Have y'all ever met?
- I don't know you,
I don't have the pleasure.
But you were in the first Scream.
- I was, I was in the first Scream.
- You were the principal.
- The principal.
- And you had an epic death.
- I did!
- [Kelly] I know, I was gonna say
he didn't make the next one.
(Kelly laughs)
- No.
The director said to me,
When you're stabbed could it be
a little more excruciating?
I said, Yes, it could.
(Kelly laughing)
- And you, and in that scene
when you're like, you're hearing things
you open the door and it's
Wes Craven mopping the floor.
(audience whooping)
- Absolutely.
- [Kelly] I love that.
I love that you know
the knowledge of the first one.
- Congratulations to you.
- Thank you so much.
- [Melissa] And to you.
- Thank you.
- Well, congrats on the new movie, Carmen.
- So this is incredible.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Thank you.
- So is it based on the opera?
- [Melissa] It is, it's very, very loosely
based on the opera.
- Okay.
- It is,
- What does that mean?
I'm curious.
- Basically, it is nothing
like the opera except for,
(Kelly laughs)
- [Melissa] except for the character.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- You know, like the essence
of the character
and the energy of Carmen is there
- but the story is completely different.
It's like a modern retelling and,
- Maybe a prequel to like
maybe who she was before.
- You know what?
That's what I say,
but I don't know that that's the truth.
But in my mind it's
kind of like an origin story.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I like that.
- [Melissa] Yeah. I like it, too..
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Alright, well you connected
with the story in a
personal way, so how so?
- Well, I'm Mexican and this
(audience clapping)
thank you.
(audience cheering and clapping)
And I, so when I moved to the US
I would only, almost only, exclusively
get offers for, or like
get auditions for either playing
like drug cartel related stuff
- [Kelly] Oh.
Or like immigration related stuff.
And I said to my team from the beginning,
I was like I'm not going to go out
for those roles
because there's so much of that,
and it's not all that we are.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- And then, and then
- Absolutely.
- But then when Carmen came along,
it was such an interesting,
like beautiful
dance,
like epic romantic way
of telling an immigration story
that I was like, I don't,
I've never seen it done like this.
It's a woman that's like
running from danger
across the border
to find a better life.
And along the way she falls in love
with this guy that, you know,
is actually trying to prevent her
from crossing the border
but then they end up
running away together. And
- Oh, I like that tension.
- Yeah. Right?
- Yeah.
- And it's Paul Mescal.
- I like that.
- I mean
- Okay. Okay.
- But so, when I, when I heard,
when I saw the script
and Benjamin Millepied,
our incredible director's vision,
I was like maybe this is a different way
of telling a story and getting through
to people about like
The real life necessity
that these people are going through,
and the dangers in a very like,
romantic, musical way.
- Yeah. It's the best way is art.
- Yeah.
- In general, is to teach people
and educate people.
- Yeah.
- I agree with that.
Do you, Henry, do you have
a real personal connection
with like, any of your characters
you've ever played?
- I think that every great character
is inside us.
Man or woman.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- And our job is to find that kernel,
and then you add on the
condition of your life
and your imagination.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- What a stellar answer!
- I've always felt,
I don't know if you feel like this.
Because I'm not the type of actor
that can like,
disappear into a role
because my way into a character
is always my personal connection to them.
And to me, every character that I play
is like a version of Melissa,
if I had been born under
these circumstances
at this time period.
- And that is why you are authentic.
Even when you're sitting here talking,
you just seem to be having a conversation
with the audience and Kelly.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- I like how you say Melissa.
(Melissa chuckling)
- I loved, I saw in the teleprompter my,
my last name, Barrera,
- But we're, is it rolled Rs,
generally, though?
- (rolling Rs) Barrera.
- [Kelly] (rolling Rs) Barrera.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I would've done that!
- Yeah, you can.
- I know.
But, I always ask people how you do it,
because I hate,
that's my biggest pet peeve.
But I never knew it was my pet peeve
before this show.
- [Melissa] Yeah.
- But it's like everybody
tries to American,
Not you.
I just mean people
- [Melissa] Yeah.
- trying to Americanize names
to like make it in.
I'm like, we're a melting pot
filled with many different cultures.
Like we can all say Melissa,
- [Melissa] But you're a musician.
You have good ear.
That's why you can. I find that
- [Kelly] Well then all you musicians,
you can do it.
(audience responding)
- Like, it's like I just, it's not
but I think if we're trained
from childhood to like say,
Melissa is beautiful.
It sounds beautiful.
- [Melissa] Right. Thank you.
- It sounds lyrical.
Like I love it.
- It's like a beautiful melody.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Next time I'm introducing you that way.
- [Melissa] Right.
- I didn't know or I would've.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Anyway, we need to do
another commercial break.
But you can see Melisa
in Scream Six out now
and in Carmen, which hits theaters
in Los Angeles and New York April 21st,
and nationwide in May.
I cannot wait to see it.